hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones Q&A the week just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened in season six so far so
I'm also gonna talk a little bit about
Season seven they confirmed that it's
gonna be a later start date I know it's
kind of a bummer now our watch has begun
they basically said that because winter
has come they can't shoot the show
during the summer like they normally
would like they'd be shooting it really
soon but because summertime and Northern
Ireland isn't most conducive for doing
winter type scenes they just they have
to wait a little bit longer in the year
to start filming
meaning that episodes are gonna come a
little bit later in addition to being a
slightly shorter season so under normal
circumstances the show would premiere at
the beginning of April this season it
was delayed by a couple weeks so I think
that it'll be a couple weeks after that
like it'll premiere sometime in May
usually they wait till late in the year
to announce like a ballpark figure like
oh we expect it to start sometime in May
or you know it might not start oh dude I
don't think it's gonna be that late but
just don't expect them to give you a
hard date anytime soon but on to
question it's a lot of little finger
Tyrion being the third head of the
Dragon John and Danny stuff so here we
go first question edge future asks how
will Cersei die in your opinion so what
I think the message with Cersei is is
that she'll become the tyrant that
everyone fears and everyone will rise up
to crush her but I do I really want to
see Jaime kill her but the other side of
that Braavosi coin would be aria
crossing her off our list the poetic
compromise would be if Aria poisoned her
wine because wine is such a big deal for
Cersei and then as she's slowly choking
then Jamie runs her through Mad King
style but either way the minute she blew
up the great set and Tommen killed
himself that was it for her she's
absolutely marked for death but because
Lena Headey is so fantastic and Cersei
is such a great character I think
they're gonna keep around as long as
possible like they'll definitely kill
her off in some amazing way but just
said have spikes she will outlive most
of the other characters on the show that
they plan on killing off next question
and virtual super soldier asks John and
Daenerys his child will be the one who
was promised and then you know nice
little joke so yeah there were actually
a couple people that suggested this
there's a lot of people based on the
books that think that Daenerys might be
barren she does have a miscarriage
towards the end of book five so she can
at least get pregnant we don't know if
she can actually carry a child to term
though
the reality of the situation is is that
I think that John and Daenerys will have
to form an alliance
maybe that's bound by marriage but I'm
not expecting any children from them
that feels like it would move into
fanfiction territory George are Martin
tees the Lord of the Rings type ending
very bittersweet now when most people
think of that they think of aragorn's
wedding you know so a very happy
occasion but I'm thinking more about the
end of that like when people just wait
off into the distance and then people
like Samwise or Samwell on Game of
Thrones or left to try and build
happiness and what's left after this big
conflict is over so if anyone's left
alive like if anyone's left in the
rubble but you know just like really sad
because their friends have died it's
gonna be Samwell Gilly and little Sam
well next question no trees asks I think
that John and Danny are both promised
but what about Tyrion as the third
person could he also be a Targaryen well
just to answer that I think that if
there's gonna be like a third person to
ride dragons in like a metaphorical
third head of the dragon I do think that
it'll be Tyrion I don't know necessarily
that they'll go with Tyrion as a
Targaryen on the show though the show
has only tease that the Dragons trust
Tyrion that whole speech of his I mean
who's really touching how when he was a
little kid he was getting ready for his
birthday he said that all he wanted was
a baby dragon it didn't even have to be
a big one and look here you are so I
think they're setting up some more
season seven Tyrion dragon moments but
just to explain when when people talk
about Tyrion maybe being a secret
Targaryen I get you're not really a
character on Game of Thrones until you
might be a secret Targaryen this is like
an inside joke but people think that the
Mad King had a thing for Tyrians mother
and had his way with her and Tyrion was
the product of that union and that's one
of the reasons why Tywin hates him so
much mostly I think it's because of his
deformity and because Tywin really loved
his wife and she died in childbirth so
he kind of blames Tyrion for that and on
top of that he looks like an imp next
question surah it asks how awesome would
it be if the song Rhaegar sang at
Harrenhal was for Lyanna stark and it's
the Song of Ice and Fire
yeah I'd definitely be interested to see
if the show actually does Rhaegar and he
sings a song I think we'll definitely
see Rhaegar eventually in the house of
the undying when Daenerys has a vision
she sees Rhaegar and he talks about this
new baby that he's cradling saying that
his song is a song of ice and fire
but because Barristan Selmy on the TV
show teased Rhaegar singing so much I
think it's a definite possibility we
could see him sing on the show they have
done a good job of paying off moments
that they tease like that like little
bits of information
so they've teased tourney at Harrenhal
they've teased Rhaegar singing so
presumably they will show that to us
eventually
next question Beto asks even if R + L
equals J isn't he's still a bastard as
his father was married to another woman
wouldn't Daenerys have more right to the
throne than him due to this well John's
status as a bastard really only depends
on Rhaegar being legitimately married to
Leon a start so there's like a couple
hoops they have to jump through but I
don't think that the show is gonna fully
explain I don't think it's gonna matter
like the people in the north have
already crowned him King Liana Mormont's
like I don't care who he is
he's our king so I think that the shows
was gonna stick with that if jon is
still a bastard then technically yes
Daenerys would have a stronger claim to
the throne next question and Travis asks
any thoughts on the Shara Dane reading
the books made me think that she played
a significant role at first I thought
she'd be John's mother after she got
busy with Ned or Brandon well okay so
ashara dayne so far on the show she is
the person that Ned Stark took dawn to
at Starfall after Arthur Dayne died at
the Tower of joy like he took his
ancestral blade home while you know with
the baby in tow the reason that people
assume that ashara dayne was Jon Snow's
mother was because of the proximity and
time to when Jon Snow was born like how
old he was and when Ned was at Starfall
in the grander scheme of things
Barristan Selmy actually had a big thing
for her when they were young at the
tourney of Harrenhal had he beat Rhaegar
at the joust in that final match he
would have honored a shara Dayne the
same way Rhaegar ended up honoring
Lyanna stark causing that big scandal
next question Nicholas asks what do you
think about the theory of the Dragons
being under Winterfell yeah there are a
lot of people that wonder if there might
be a clutch of dragon eggs under
Winterfell it's totally possible but I
think at this point in the narrative
Jon Snow is the dragon of Winterfell
like the lore has become the metaphor
it's kind of the same thing with the
zora high like people believe there was
like an actual mythical figure when
really it's more of a metaphor you know
just someone who's a mythical leader
that leads them to victory which is you
know why I think there are multiple
loves or high type people even if no one
actually calls them that
the only people that have actually used
that term or the red priests everyone
else like if you look at the wildlings
they don't think of Jon Snow as the king
they just think of him as someone to
lead them through the long night just
like Daenerys his followers think of her
so if there were actually dragons under
Winterfell at one time like a like a
long long time ago there probably aren't
any more and now the only dragon at
Winterfell is Jon Snow next question and
Monica asks I don't really understand
the Targaryen fireproof thing Daenerys
is the only one of the show that's been
proven to be immune to fire the series
died because of the melted gold Khal
Drogo threw on him he was pure Targaryen
just like his sister Jon Snow seemed to
make a scream getting burped when he
threw the fire at the white saving the
Lord Commander I'm so confused
okay so what the show is doing is it's
just making Daenerys seem like she has a
superpower that she has dragons and she
is immune to fire but the show has like
turned it into a thing that's way bigger
than it is in the books like Jon Snow
seems like he's almost immortal he's
actually a warg in real life too but the
show hasn't really done that yet
Daenerys seems like she's fireproof like
each of them has one big thing that they
can call a superpower but in reality the
way George r Martin explains it is that
you know Targaryen are fireproof when
blood magic is in play
otherwise they just have a minor
resistance to heat next question am 723
how was Arya able to use another face
when she left Braavos so there's a
couple theories about this none of them
make any sense it really it really just
makes you mad if you try to overanalyze
this like the show just wanted to have
this big twist so it really just through
logic out the window part of the problem
with Arya face swapping that girl at the
twins is that it wouldn't make you
taller like she's way taller than Maisie
Williams in real life that actress and
she has like way bigger boobs
switching faces doesn't make your body
change shape so she wouldn't get any
taller and she wouldn't grow any boobs
but the TV show because it wanted to
have that twist just kind of threw that
at the window it's like please don't pay
attention to the logic here so if you
want to come up with like a funny
explanation for how she changed faces
you could say that she pocketed a couple
faces with her when she left Braavos but
in reality that the TV show just isn't
bothering to explain that next question
Chris asks a whole bunch a little finger
question so I like the idea about the
little finger video
but I'm gonna talk a little bit about
what I think is gonna be happening with
him next season so Littlefinger is all
about twisting salsa against Jon Snow
and as stupid as that seems like Sansa
should trust Jon Snow it's not like he's
trying to do anything Littlefinger is
gonna do everything he can to make her
believe like she has to turn on him
Littlefinger tends to work better behind
the scenes in the shadows so I think
they're mostly going to use his
storyline to create drama like filler
drama until they're ready to battle the
White Walkers because that's like the
big external threat but you need to have
internal threats and everybody seems to
love Jon Snow the wildlings love him all
the northerners love him Littlefinger is
the only person who hates the [ __ ] out
of Jon Snow so he's probably going to do
everything he can to poison Sansa
against Jon next question and Julianne
asks do you think that Howland Reed will
appear in any of the two seasons to
reveal Jon Snow's true parentage
actually no I think the show will find
another way to do it so one I don't
think that anybody's gonna question his
legitimacy to lead so it won't really be
that big of an issue but I think the
brand will probably the one to tell him
regardless of what brand tells him or
doesn't tell him on top of all that I
think that eventually Jon Snow will come
face to face with the dragon and it will
cozy up to him a little bit and that
will be like the show's way of letting
Daenerys know that he's a good person
because of the dragons like him how bad
can he be but I don't think that there's
ever gonna be a situation where I'll
have to prove that he's a Targaryen if
he does have to prove it to Daenerys I
think that the dragons will prove that
for her but thank you everyone for so
many questions these are always a ton of
fun to do comic-con is coming up in a
couple weeks so I will do like a Comic
Con specific video explaining what all
those videos are gonna look like they've
only announced some of the actors
they're bringing they haven't really
said what they're gonna show off they'll
probably do a blooper reel
maybe they'll tease stuff about next
season I think that they'll at least
tease it even if they're not gonna have
footage because of course is they're not
gonna shoot for a while then they won't
have any footage once we learn a little
bit more about their plans I'll do a
preview video just explaining how my
videos are going to work whenever that
stuff comes but congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Christopher you
win a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel for contact details so
because I realized that I haven't done
like episode ranking for season six like
ranked all my season six episodes
top to bottom that's probably what my
next bonus video will be so I'll post
that on Sunday so be sure to subscribe
to get that they'll also be a new round
of the giveaway when I post that too
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my essaouira
high video I just talked about how the
prophecy is gonna be twisted it's gonna
turn into more of a metaphor than the
literal thing and you can click here for
my spider-man homecoming Thor Ragnarok
behind the scenes videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you